we got a pond and catch Bigfoot Bigfoot
in a cage oh whoa what do you get that
bond foot I hit G for that hunting how
do you get the gun hit - I don't burn
the forest down all right let's head out
let's roll out
I got the trek again okay I got a branch
what I ripped the brain job we got a
hood that son of a [ __ ] I'm setting up
a tracking camera right here the camera
it's a tracking it's a tracking device
high-tech one sweet sweet inventions I
bought it right from a key oh yeah
if Bigfoot comes this way I'm placing a
trap here okay don't walk what did I say
huh why did I say why did I say it thank
you don't walk on the trap Jesus Christ
we got a mission we got a fine big food
I think his name is Osso Jack's okay see
this is what checks Potosi of course he
lives in this forest we're in the Irish
woods there's potatoes every we're
making the trees
he's rare he doesn't leave his house
very often what was that rip the bridge
Oh for [ __ ] sake you scared the piss
out of me
right alright I think we decided oh
where I got the gun ready or in the
which nest now hmm you that what hey
breathing TV the potato trees is it the
potato trees don't lose you I didn't
know you walked away and going after is
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
a serious king awesome oh my god
and that's unrealistic thunder okay oh
my god any time it's a look oh it's
right in front of me Champa enemy
[Music]
what the [ __ ] wait there's something
there suffocation Jasper National Park
we can't go there I'm starting to
believe this Bigfoot spread I see man
doesn't really doesn't exist you go we
already been over there I am lost I am
lost we're lost Ken goddamnit I'm wet
I'm tired I just want to take a man oh
[ __ ] we got night vision I forgot oh
yeah he did it oh yeah hold right Jesus
Christ gives a [ __ ] all right
he's out here somewhere I knew it
I can smell these potatoes
[Music]
flippity nice Bush excited per second
hey can you stop moving I'm trying to
play this [ __ ] game [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] we gotta get the rope get the
rope rope look you barely did any damage
shut up dude you gotta get that we gotta
track it with the track dude I'm almost
dead we gotta go back to camp and ski oh
my god I don't want a dad like am told
to help me leave me alone out here with
him okay the keep running straight as he
came right for us son of a [ __ ] it's
frickin Q he's Q for a man horses [ __ ]
to you all right let's go back to the
camp the camp is where he is
[Applause]
why do you have a guy you in the room
with the cod a guy shoot him with a
tracking gun my suppose like though a
[ __ ] under his feet or something I
understand no it said you changed
bullets would say oh oh hey oh the
cameras they weren't coming screams holy
[ __ ] yes see him any side of the Saints
I don't know man there's a gun there oh
my god it was on the [ __ ] roof right
now
now we're gonna get des reload your gun
yet yes of course what do you think I'm
stupid
all right so this map is actually pretty
big like we found him in the area behind
us and I see his life bar at the top
it's barely wet Dan we gotta get him on
the trap and you gotta get it and forget
it the rope all right to rule maybe we
shouldn't have wasted all the tramps do
you have any trappers put you right here
no no save the trap save the trap okay
put some meat in this trap you see
where's the media necks [ __ ] meat and
you didn't [ __ ] tell me dude I could
have eaten man [ __ ] let's back up for
now okay here you hear that that's you
walking
no that's not the stimulus of them
breathing blue don't shoot him don't
shoot attract him traca traca traca ja a
straight-ahead is gonna run down the map
oh yeah baby here we go get its [ __ ]
earning town so fast
damn he's fast but it's gone in the lake
for a little swimming oh yeah skinny-dip
ah she's still moving flashed where the
[ __ ] is he going let's cut through the
lake swim through yeah all right
actually he's gonna go around right we
should meet him on the other side by the
bridge where the [ __ ] is he going off
the map oh [ __ ] I'm drowning [ __ ] he's
going off the [ __ ] grid yeah crap
because his map how do we how do we find
him so many times and now he's like off
of the middle of nowhere no mate no
goddang says he's [ __ ] camping dude
it's not fair oh my god alright we need
to lay that trap again I only picked it
l only picked up one meet at the fridge
for [ __ ] sake man I mean yeah we're
we're done now well you really hit him
good didn't yet and I really don't
understand how how he was to catch him
he's freaking he's know is going the
other way now you see where he's going
he's going towards our direction right
you can turn a little bit so put a trap
anyway here okay let me back the [ __ ] up
turn up the flashlight and then we wait
you don't have any meat do you
there's no meat [ __ ] you come back to
this I don't know I think it's coming
straight as though hey [ __ ] bro are you
okay we're actually we should stay by
the trash
stay by the trap see you trapping hey
Bigfoot last I know you can see you
let's go another way now ah [ __ ] he knew
oh there is right in front of us hey
Bigfoot how do you like this you ever
killed a big foot before shot him what
the [ __ ] why did it sound like a goddamn
cow noises that can't we I wasted a
tracking bullet on it look it's on the
[ __ ] radar
damn it I shot the wrong bullet it's on
the other side there is there is
oh let's sneak up on him what the [ __ ]
god damn again the [ __ ] sake you're a
lousy shot like your lousy side sorry ma
there's someone in base camp it looks go
together you know oh my
it's so yellow
oh my he probably went on the trap he
went on the trap ha ha
what strip okay you go to number two
I'll go to number one all right all
right it's bad I did we go find it we'll
gonna be a little scared
okay fine I'll go to - - because I'm go
back to the cameras and terrify them hey
we can't loosen this damn
okay nose I heard him pause the freaking
moose again it could have been the moose
[Music]
I'm guessing he's not on the track [ __ ]
I wouldn't shoot I panicked I panicked
it's a track it's not track oh the green
blood the ground you followed the blood
walk in the trap oh maybe this is the
ladies of the one trap you know there
was never a trap on that one least we
know he's alive her around here I feel
like we're doing okay we're not doing
bad it's just it takes four guiding
every final key picture you Kelvin yeah
it's like the point of game is to catch
him but he knows that's all there is to
do so it's gotta be hard right track I
got him track this time oh yeah we're
gonna [ __ ] kill that [ __ ] ass rare
bullets would kill I got 60 bullets
seems
I hit him oh god I'm I was heading 360
no skills he's gonna do that [ __ ]
thing where you go sit away there again
we went back to it
yeah
[Music]
[Laughter]
you
[Music]
[Applause]